family on it through you know make the
world's funniest clown
we can fix that
zero let's turn that frown upside down
there are good people in Gotham like who
the Sheep who locked the doors and crawl
under the bed basic kid comes the masked
hero
oh this is about doing what's right you
are being a hero tell you what buddy
I'll give you a fighting chance let's do
this mono Ilana
my little conquistadora come on
Oh
[Music]
yes
hey youtubers is Charlie a bunch of you
guys requested a Gotham video so here we
go there's spoilers for the mid-season
finale it's a little bit weird because
there's a three-month break typically
that happens before December but
whatever is coming back in April in
Jerome came back he's been dead he
brought the show back to life with him
so let's turn that frown upside down so
because this is DC TV I'll say new round
of the flash ring starts now at all
announced a new winner at the end of
this all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about the
Joker on this video a lot of people are
feeling like Jerome's version of the
Joker is actually going to be better
than Jared Leto's here and everything I
help you you help me
by erasing my mind was instated memories
I had no you left me in a black hole of
rage and confusion but awesome medicine
you practice dr. Quinzel what are you
gonna do you're gonna kill me mr. Jarry
what
oh I'm not idea I'm just gonna hurt you
really really bad do you think so well I
can take it I wouldn't want you to break
those perfect porcelain cap teeth when
the juice is your brain now he has a lot
more time to develop the character he
says the last couple of seasons so TV in
general is just better for character
development yes I do think that Jared
Leto is a better actor but the character
is much better on Gotham right now so
maybe that will change in the future in
the DC EU they'll be plenty of Joker to
go around there were a couple big Easter
eggs that they lay like James remar
character the uncle coming who's part of
the court of owls in the glass owl that
was supposed to leave them there all
dressed that in a second the big thing
everyone's talking about is Bruce Wayne
proto Batman versus the proto Joker
although we can just call him the Joker
he's really a new 52 version of the
Joker mixed with Mark Hamill's animated
Joker Cameron Monaghan actually had a
wonderful actor said that he was
inspired by Mark Hamill's Joker when he
was coming up with his mannerisms in the
way his character works but because of
the stapled on face he's a bit new 52
and the really cool thing is that this
carnival setting for the Joker's
execution of Batman attempted execution
of Batman is that it goes back to the
origins of the Bill Finger Bob Kane
Joker so a lot of you probably know that
there's no true origin story to the
Joker everyone's just embraced the idea
that he has no defined origin story
there have been a bunch of different
versions the Red Hood the shows done
that before but really the Joker
character is best when you don't try to
nail him down to any definitive story he
just utter chaos and he brings
everything a lot just like he brought
the show back to life whenever he came
back so there's this story that Bill
Finger would go to Coney Island and
there was this Joker face on one of the
rides that would just give him
nightmares and that served as partial
inspiration for the creation in the look
of the Joker so typically when they do
really big scenes like this like the
immovable object meets the unstoppable
force they try to do them in as cool
away as possible
so
this is a really cool story line it was
also very comic-book accurate to the
original intentions of Bill Finger Bob
Kane so where we get really excited when
I spot stuff like that the big Batman
scene that everyone's talking about as
they were duking it out was when he said
I will not kill he's forming his
identity as the Batman and the Joker is
forcing him to do it just like in the
Nolan trilogy when the rise of the
Batman gave rise to the Joker in fact
that actually reminds me Heath Ledger's
probably still my favorite Joker he
lifted a scene of dialogue directly from
Heath Ledger's Joker so we should
actually add that to the mix to inspired
by Mark Hamill's Joker as well as Heath
Ledger because they basically lifted
that scene right out of the Dark Knight
oh how I wanted that you're not even if
you'd like to me as a man you're just a
freak like me I need you right now
when I don't now cast you out like a
leper see they're balls they're cold a
bad joke dropped at the first sign of
trouble they're only as good as the
world allows them to be I'll show ya
when the chips are down
these civilized people they'll eat each
other see I'm not a monster
I'm just ahead of the curve but the
other really big twist
so Gordon's uncle who's coming in to
help him James remar you probably
remember him from Dexter so it's always
fun to see him play really crazy
characters is part of the court of owls
himself and they don't know it so you
can see that the court of owls is
becoming a much bigger thing on the show
Bruce and Alfred have been tracking down
the glass owl this whole time hoping
that it holds a clue and then Jerome
smashes it at the beginning of the
episode they might try to reconstruct it
and in doing so find a clue that will
lead them closer to the court but David
Mizzou's the actor who plays Bruce was
saying that the court about will
fundamentally change Bruce so court of
owls itself is a very new 52 thing so
there's a lot of new 52 comic book stuff
happening especially with the really big
characters like the Joker the court of
owls the Batman character so if you like
that run this is actually going to be a
lot of fun for you what about the big
twist at the end of the episode the
Riddler shoots and tries to kill penguin
pushing him into the bay the next
episode when we come back is called how
the Riddler got his name he'll be
wearing the full-on costume so of course
the Penguins not dead in fact one of the
upcoming episodes is called a fish out
of the sea so you see some of the
lasting impact fish Mooney has had on
the penguin character so everything is
just getting crazier and crazier as we
move towards the season finale so if you
guys have special quests for Gotham
bonus videos for characters or big plot
points or anything like that just let me
know in the comments really the only
reason I stopped doing weekly Gotham
videos a while ago it's just because
interest dropped so low from week to
week but I'm always happy to do bonus
videos the same goes for agents of
shield too a lot of you're requesting
agents of shield so there's something
specially you guys want a video about
just let me know in the comments I'm
always happy to do stuff like that it's
always fun to dig through episodes and I
do still watch Gotham I still watch
agents of shield there's a ton of stuff
that I watch that I don't do videos for
but there's a couple things that will be
coming up like Legion is starting next
week I'll be doing a video for the first
episodes we can decide whether or not
we'd like it if we want to do it week to
week I'll keep doing videos so Legion
coming up next week it's going to be a
wednesday night show I'll be posting
that video Thursday morning but there's
going to be a whole bunch more Super
Bowl trailers coming this weekend if you
have special requests there's going to
be strangers being season 2 dropping so
I'll try to do as many videos as
possible so maybe three videos tomorrow
at least two but congratulations to the
new flash ring giveaway winner luke wolf
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there will be a new
round the next time I post a DC video
while you wait so that you can click
here for the new flash new Caesar and
you can click here for more Super Bowl
trailers thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high box I'll see you in
the next video